there is a poop bus in London yeah a bus
powered by poop we've got a picture of
it I'll tell you a little bit more about
it it is a bus powered by bio methane
gas which is his legs that's gonna be a
whole other story which we will cover
the bus is powered by bio methane gas
which is generated through the treatment
of human food and waste and it made its
maiden voyage in England this month
we've got a little bit more info for you
it seats 40 passengers and can travel up
to 186 miles on one tank Oh ding ding
ding well done Jimmy the amount of gas
it takes to produce one tank is how much
is produced annually by five people do
you have a joke about Mexican food or
anything you want to get in there no you
got nothing okay impurities are removed
to create quote virtually odorless
emissions and when used to power
vehicles it can reduce greenhouse
emissions by 88% compared to gasoline my
father taught me how to read stories put
the graphic back up there if you could
real quick just that last graphic there
there's only one word and that whole
thing that matters virtually virtually
does not mean order list yes there are
missions are what they call silent but
deadly poop bus I mean this is pretty
good right we talked about the green
stuff all the time we're not talking
about the we this time from our green
energy and we talked about global
warming and climate change and all this
stuff but it seems to me this is not
something that America will be able to
wrap its brain or any people are gonna
be looking at those buses and that's
gonna create a log jam a traffic that's
what I think
well more I don't know keep going yeah I
don't know it just seems to me like some
effort to how can we make riding the
buses slightly less unpleasant
experience
slightly less excuse me okay try that
yet yeah I would think riding the bus is
slightly less pleasant experience you
know rides the bus guys people escaped
mental patients court-martial GIS the
indigent and the haunted that's it yeah
that's right this of that see I'm glad
you laugh of that because that is Jay
Leno on Letterman like 19
85 yes a class like that when he was at
his best Dave you know who rides the bus
escaped mental patients court-martial G
is the indigent the haunted and
Letterman goes the haunted Jay goes the
haunted he was funny into that what you
want that was the peak of Leno do you
think we could ever do something like
this in the end ice it's obviously we
should be doing this kind of thing if it
works I thought they were already
powered by [ __ ] are you kidding they're
not they're not oh I think doesn't
Willie Nelson have a bus that's powered
by [ __ ] I think his bus is powered by
weed I was outside his tour bus once and
that thing wreaked really yeah that's a
serious weed but really you think we can
do it as a Taco Bell commercials was in
that power I'm sorry good I don't
believe this stuff I just don't like I
mean yes of course we should 88% mean
again if it eliminates our reliance this
make great senses I'm asleep it'll work
for a bus I go work for a car yeah right
so I'm you know you want smart people
behind this I'm working on this and and
to go back to maybe the first clip we
did or whatever an earlier clip here on
the room report posted by Chuck Todd and
dumb people running for the Senate
running for the house yes is
inconceivable that there are enough
American legislators especially in
position power now who would advocate
this yeah so baby by the way and maybe
not the president either I don't want to
make it seem like Barack Obama be like
oh no let's devote our resources to
poopsies to stuff like this yeah yeah so
that's my final point on this we can't
even get behind the electric car right
like we still have problems with the
electric car they're still fighting
Tesla all over the country so poop bus
probably not gonna happen here for a
while or we agreed if we can't get the
electric one going the poop one that's
for some car you see it's 95 miles to go
95 that's incredible it says it right on
the screen 95 miles to go that's a lot
of [ __ ] yeah give me one more [ __ ] joke
bring us home no I wish they would rack
no I'm done okay you're done